between federal local and state when it
comes to the evictions
well i think that's one of the issues
definitely throughout
the panda that has been highlighted
and we've seen various levels of success
or lack of success around coordination i
couldn't agree with you more
i'll put up with you more how best um
do you think we can get out the benefits
of the american rescue plan
and and which populations have we found
that have been most difficult to reach
for example uh one of the concerns that
i've had is that we uh which is why
we're traveling around the country
just this this is meant to be a public
education campaign
so people know what they're entitled to
receive right
um for example
for people who are in the system that
fourteen hundred dollar check and all
the benefits that should flow from the
american rescue plan
um they're likely to get it in
a faster pace if they're in the system
because they pay taxes last year or they
are
the recipient of social security
benefits or medicare things like that
but if people are not in the system then
it's likely to take longer
and they're likely to be more glitches
right in terms of giving
the relief to them as quickly as
possible so we are
urging people for example file your
taxes even if you don't
you didn't have an income or a
significant income so that they're in
the system and that's one of the things
that we love your help with to let
people know how to be in the system
so they can get that direct deposit
right as quickly as possible
but what else are you all seeing in
terms of um
the folks who we may not be hearing from
even though they do need help you know i
would say to my team let's sit back and
listen to who we're not hearing from
if if we're in this region where
where would we say we're not hearing
from people i don't mean geographically
but
practically who are we hearing from
that we need to reach out to or do a
better job reaching um man vice
president
that's that's a very good question uh
because
that population we're not hearing from
and they are in the shadows
um but i do want to kind of think about
what susan
susan said that um that
you know in the distribution lines there
is a camaraderie and people are helping
uh each other but what that has has
shown me is that you do have a
transportation issue
and not only translation issues and
distribution but also transportation
issue
in getting those other services such as
the people that are in the shadows
and so um you know i know that you know
here in this community we are racking
our brains on
how do we get that information out on
how we get
uh services uh to those individuals or
those individuals to the services
uh that they need and so i think we do
need to focus
on proportional transportation um and i
also think that
those individuals that are in the
shadows um
it's a traumatic time and so there are
some um
some mental health issues i'm not saying
that uh
they're mentally ill but it's a shock
you know when you go through it
so it's a lot of trauma uh so i think
it's very fascinating
you know there are a lot of different
pieces but i do think that
you know my biggest thing is
transportation and counseling and i
um you know we uh support some
legislation to where
uh where we're subsidizing uh private
uh transportation companies uh to go out
and uh transport
individuals to services and such as
grocery stores and things like that so
i think we need to again you know
try to target um that transportation or
that
uh you know that outreach peace
well for education it's more about who
we don't see
yeah these are children who are learning
remotely
and they still have attendance issues
for families who are esol families
getting those bilingual services out to
them
we we have bilingual interpreters who
we try to send out to get that
information out to them
but those are the individuals that where
we see
that we don't see are are the ones
struggling
and those are the same children that we
worry
if you're not coming to grab and go how
are you getting food
during the day even though we have this
available
for them so it goes all back to
transportation being evicted
it's kind of a vicious cycle that we see
the evidence in in the school district
that one they're not
they're chronically absent or they're
learning remotely
even though they have the up they have
the equipment the resources the internet
we
take care of the internet their
environment may not be conducive
to having school six hours during the
day
there's other things happening and those
are the children that
keep me up at night that we're worried
about how can we support them
because we can't see them we can't get
to them
as easily as students who are coming
into
brick and mortar and now the vice
president
we could talk about this all for hours
and days
and we're all so passionate about this
but we also want to be very respectful
of your time
um but this isn't all hands on deck i
think for everybody across this entire
country
it is making sure that the incredible
work that you and the president are
doing and our members of congress
is getting that information flowing down
to the local levels the state level
and allowing us the opportunity to be
empowered to educate all these
individuals too about all
of the resources and all the benefits
that they're entitled to making sure
we bring people into the system so again
thank you for being here
the first step is you being here helping
this community
community understand uh the important
work and what you are doing here
and now hopefully all those who are
standing here all the media that we are
going to help
to disseminate this information to our
communities and
we cannot just thank you enough for the
support that you and the president have
been giving to us
well thank you commissioner and um it is
very important to the president
that we are on the ground
with all of you who have been for over a
year
every day with many many sleepless
nights
the work you all have been doing
is extraordinary i think that there is
um i'm certain actually
that history is gonna show that
this was a moment of extreme crisis
that uh challenged us and there
were the heroes that just showed up
they could use the angels walking around
us the heroes that just showed up
which includes your volunteers which
includes
these incredible the the families who
have a car who are picking up the
neighbors to help them come
to be in line the the just the frontline
work
there's so many heroes that have been
revealed to the rest of us
and and it should give us a sense of
hope and a sense of faith in who
we all are um but you all been doing
work on the ground
and so yes part of the reason i'm here
is to talk about the american rescue
plan but only to
to let you know that it was designed and
the spirit behind
it was intended to to help you
do the work you all have been doing
every day and um
again i think that without any question
in this moment of crisis the kindness
of humanity has revealed itself
the generosity of spirit the courage
the commitment and um let's
let that kind of guide our optimism in
this moment of crisis
and again all of that to say thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you
you'll be well okay and help us on the
way
it's on the way yes commissioner
thank you
okay
you